[Music]
introducing con Migo for districts Khan
Academy's AI powered student tutor and
teaching assistant is Paving the way for
a new era of learning in the classroom I
could see it as a teacher virtual
assistant I could see it as a virtual
assistant for the kids too but really
helping teachers understand data
disseminate the data how come formulate
small groups give them specific
suggestions and recommendations with
Khan mego get students personalized
feedback and support right when they
need it he actually offers step-by-step
instructions but not to the point where
it gives the answer to the student but
it guides them enough where if the
student reads and goes along with it it
actually helps them achieve the answer
without giving it to them it's almost
like your own little personal virtual
assistant with you at all times it gives
them an ability to be self-sufficient in
a way so it's really great tool and I
think Khan Academy is leading us through
that path uh let's support the kids
let's manage it let's monitor it so that
then we can allow the educational world
to look at how can this really impact
education and how can it make it better
can Amigo activity conmigo is already
helping teachers get to their
instruction Faster by differentiating
student learning each student has their
own level of learning all level pacing
instead of having everyone stuck at one
pace you're able to with that
essentially virtual assistant have the
student go at their own pace and
basically you're able to go to those
students that need the most amount of
help and let the ones that are able to
move on their own just Excel buy-in is
so important like student engagement is
the key to education if the students are
able to ask the personalized questions
and it gives an answer that's relevant
to them they're going to feel more
empowered to do the work and feel
inspired to try to learn these things
that otherwise they might say what's the
point so you'll get the lesson and then
it's easier to have the little conmingle
button there so they're able to ask
those questions as they're reading or
annotating while doing the lesson so
they don't have to stop and switch gears
it's kind of like a seamless process and
I think that's the smartest idea like
seamlessly integrating AI into the
foundation of education and the learning
that we normally do with built-in
safeguards for student interaction and
chat reports for parents and teachers
Khan Academy brings its trusted content
into the world of AI that along with the
benefits of Khan Academy districts
partnership such as professional
development personal support and
data-driven Reporting the future of
learning is just a few clicks away it is
wonderful working with Khan Academy in
trying to really supplement students
academic learning and we're really
excited about the promise that the
platform brings to helping students
continue to grow and deepen their
knowledge based on their own interests
as well as collaborative needs which the
teacher determines so this is an
exciting time for us to be working in
this partnership together to see what
the future will bring with AI and how we
can continue to grow to really support
students
[Music]